[Music]
thank you for the introduction as was
said I name is Pierre Lenz I am senior
geospatial analyst at distillery Inc we
were an ad Tech and Marquette company I
was asked to do a couple of interesting
statistics on the size of the company
and what we do at the very beginning we
pull in event data and those events can
be a person seeing an ad on a web page a
pixel being fired a person showing up at
a location that's the world that I live
in the location data or any one of
dozens of other inputs and every day we
collect about 200 billion of those which
blows my mind every time I say that
number I started four years ago and I
remember the party that we had when we
put had our first 1 billion input day
and to be at 200 just blows my mind
somewhere around 25 petabytes of data in
our data store majority of that is
sitting in Hadoop with Cassandra hive in
a little tiny bit of spark we're really
early hive hive user we love sequel data
somewhere between two and five thousand
servers and that's a very big range and
that is because literally as I'm
standing here our infrastructure people
are building a new cage in New Jersey
and I literally have no idea how many
servers are running it now and we have
run all of our own systems we work in a
world where the average event has a
timeout we have to have we have to have
our machine learning generate a response
on that event in 250 milliseconds most
of that time is actually going to be
spent traveling back and forth and
literally in the wire the packet travel
time my geospatial component has a 15
millisecond timeout you can't do that on
any kind of cloud we build our own
servers we run our own our own cages we
wire our own
it's a lot of fun and cool custom stuff
when we talk about what tools we use it
very often comes down to oh we bent to
build a custom things for that oh we had
to build a custom thing for that oh we
had to build a custom thing for that and
that gets annoying when you can't talk
to other people about the tools they use
luckily we don't have that problem today
today I'm talking just about data geo
data my favorite kind of data and it
tells you the kind of person I am that I
really get excited about that in fact
we're gonna talk about the most common
kind of geo data which I guarantee you
have in your database somewhere else I
am talking of course about the zip code
it's everywhere it's on your envelope
you can collect it just from mail it's
in every form that you have ever filled
out on the Internet and how many times I
can't tell you how many times I've shown
up in my stock photo supermarket in
bid-ask can you have your zip code sir
zip code utterly surrounds us as a piece
of data and it's amazing for something
that is so ubiquitous that so few people
actually understand what it is it's
caveats the problems with it and also
the great things about it we just use it
because you know cultivated laziness is
a really great thing to be that's that
that's one of the virtues of data
science so we're gonna do a fun little
trip through zip codes I think it's fun
we're gonna go to do that we have to go
back we got to go way way back to the
beginning and understand how we got to
where we are where this data comes from
and as these things tend to go when
you're talking about some kind of
something that's a piece of data being
generated by the government US
government it starts at one person
Benjamin Franklin mr. $100 bill
statesman scientist player
assistant Postmaster General of His
Majesty King George the Third's
possessions in the northern part of the
Americas a job which he took not so much
because he wanted the job but because it
let him do be a censor what things got
censored well things that newspapers
published by Benjamin Franklin not
censored newspapers not published by
Benjamin Franklin censored government
corruption goes way way back that said
Franklin did actually do real work he
set up the very beginning of the postal
system here in America an infrastructure
called the post roads you've almost
certainly seen one of them they'll be
called Albany Post Road Boston Post Road
Charleston post route their routes along
which the mail traveled back in the
early days of the postal system if you
didn't live on these roads you didn't
get the mail
you had to travel to one of the points
on this network to get it the mail was
carried by these guys
postal riders the Hat is a top hat that
would eventually become the cowboy hat
which i think is really really cool and
they would carry these giant horns which
they would blast when they got to town
irregularly in some places like
Philadelphia or New York you'd get mail
from someplace every day but if you live
in the backwoods it might be months
between these guys showing up when the
mail got there it was a big deal and
they bring it to the post office except
there was no post office you'd be
brought to the Village Inn or pub guy
would literally haul the mail in you can
see him coming through the door here
with a big bag of mail the postmaster
would be the innkeeper or the the
publican who's running it and he's a
really important person in the early
American Republic every single
postmaster was in fact appointed by the
President of the United States for a
very good reason this is a very early
implementation of peer-to-peer
networking that bag containing that mail
they're going to open it up and together
the postmaster and the post right are
gonna read through it and they're gonna
say oh this one's for here this one's
for there this one's for here this one's
for there
they're gonna decide who gets their mail
the each node in this system has to be
really really smart and there's no other
form of communication there's no
telephone system there's no telegraph
system this is it if it's not done right
the entire communication system of the
United States breaks down really really
important system but every single piece
of it has to be really really smart if
you're going to be sending a piece of
mail you're gonna address it something
like this if you're going to send it
we're going to we're gonna take a look
at all of the addresses of that
distillery has had through the years if
theoretically the building was there
back then if you wanted to send me a
piece of mail you would send it to Peter
Lenz in New York City except that's
probably not going to get to me because
what if there's another Peter Lenz what
if the postmaster has no idea who Peter
lenses so you put in hints you're gonna
send it to that Peter Lenz guy in New
York City who really needs a haircut who
works in that tall gray building on Park
Avenue with a wizard clock out front
you're gonna have to give lots and lots
of hints and eventually maybe the mail
will get to you abysmal delivery rates
definitely not 99 we're thinking maybe
seven sevens of accuracy I think I
should patent that that should be an
idea seven sevens of accuracy system got
better though within a couple of decades
the Post writers are gone they're
replaced with stage coaches the stage in
stagecoach is the distance between main
post offices in the government stopped
using people's pubs and inns as post
offices and started building real ones a
process by the way that has not yet
actually finished there are still
general stores that are also post office
in fact we're only a decade out from the
last instance of a post office in
someone's living room it's a remarkably
complicated and interesting system
anyway these post offices main post
offices that are being written between
we're gonna look something like this
there's a whole bunch of different
sorting tables there's all sorts of
different ways that you can take a look
at the mail but it's still basically the
same idea that Ben Franklin
set up you open up a piece of mail you
go through it these ones are for here
these ones are for someplace else and
you put them through the bags into
different bags the bags that are going
somewhere else
get sent off by various systems if
you're in a big city these giant tubes
here are pneumatic tubes the mail goes
in it will bits sent through by a giant
steam vacuum through the streets to
another main post office where they will
open up the bag and they will sort these
ones are for you here these ones are
first somewhere else every node sorts
the mail itself New York City still has
these in the street though they haven't
been used in something like sixty years
they're there though and they're cool
I like cool things if you're a little
farther apart you're gonna get sent by
something like this it's called a
railway post office it's a really simple
system there's a guy he's throwing the
bag of mail that's being delivered to
this town and we have the outgoing mail
here on what's called a hoop there is a
big metal hook right there in the door
what's going to happen is that hooks
gonna catch that bag as the train goes
past without stopping that guy is gonna
pull in that bag and inside the train
car is a miniature version of that post
office they're going to open the bag up
they're going to sort the mail they're
going to bag it up and it's going to go
off to the next place where they're
going to open it up and sort it again
it's a it's literally if you think -
think about it as an algorithm it's a
recursive algorithm every place you go
to you open the bag of mail you sort it
if it gets delivered here great if not
you put it in another bag of mail and
you send it off someplace hopefully
closer to the destination no guarantee
of when it's actually going to get there
but eventually it will hi the system
lasts a long time
this system of main post offices and
railway posts offs lasts almost a
hundred years it's really resilient and
it requires no centralization every node
makes a decision by itself of how it's
going to sort the mail no centralization
whatsoever but it works and your address
is going to look like something like
this
this looks remarkably similar to what we
have today
suddenly instead of putting a hint about
the guy who's gonna pick up the mail you
actually have an address what you still
have a city in the state system is
really resilient works for a long time
but by the night early part of the 1930s
it's beginning to show that it's wearing
down they try crazy things to try and
patch it airmail comes into existence
and in the very early days of airmail
they treated it the same way they
treated the railway post offices guy
throws out a bag of mail as he flies
over the town and there's a hook and he
tries to grab the mail so it can fly off
to somewhere else basically it's a way
of instead of having those sorts at each
and post office I can make a direct link
between two big cities but it's an
expensive system and it's it's a hack
it's sitting on top of the existing
system both a part of and a part of the
regulars routing and it's expensive when
it starts off it's a whole three cents
more than the regular three cent stamp
double the price crazy expensive but it
works to keep the system working for
another two decades or so by the 1950s
they're looking for another cheap fix
another system that they can build on
top of it and being the 1950s early
1960s why not stop it on top of a giant
missile they actually did this a handful
of times before somebody said holy [ __ ]
we're strapping mail on top of a missile
what are you doing
each one should cost something like 15
million dollars and cost and carried
somewhere around 250 pieces of mail I'll
let you do the math I love this one the
post the the post stamp is actually a
warship that launched the missile and
it's addressed to James a Farley
postmaster of New York City after whom
our main post office the big fancy
building across from Penn Station is
named after note though no zip code it's
not here yet we haven't come to the real
solution luckily
it's while the insane people are trying
on putting oil on top of missiles
smarter people let's call them proto
data scientists are thinking about this
problem too and they implement a hack
that actually works they say we have
cities and one of the big problems is
that most mail goes to cities and they
just go there New York City is a big
place that means we have to sort the
mail a lot of times when it gets there
let's devote let's take the concept of
city and shrink it down let's make
smaller cities so here's an example of
the first one that was done creating
postal delivery zones this is Detroit
except it's not Detroit this is actually
as far as the post office concerned 30
different cities the cities of Detroit
one through the troit 30 in your address
will look something like this new you
know I've now changed New York to New
York 16 New York City has ceased to
exist instead we have 16 City like
things that are numbered I really love
this this is this is the hackey data
scientist solution that I think that I
would have probably come up with or at
least I'd like to think I came up with
we take a thing that people were already
familiar with cities and we made this
other parallel thing that looks very
similar but is not quite exactly the
same but it worked
it allowed post offices to be much more
efficient about their routing instead of
sending something to New York City and
having it to be Reese or did dozens of
times to get it to its destination its
New York 16 and whatever post office is
in New York 16 will actually make the
decision of how to decide it for the
first time we've introduced
centralization in some kind of routing
algorithm into the postal system post
office loves it it really is great they
want to extend it everywhere so they
come up with the zone improvement plan
which again after millions of dollars
they changed to zip code this is all of
your faces right now you know what a zip
code looks like you're born look knowing
what this league looks like but how is
it actually work
what the hell is a zip code so this
little graphic comes out 1963 as the zip
code is introduced and has the virtues
of being correct and all of the pain
points of explaining absolutely nothing
so let's dig into what a zip code really
is it's not a number their routing
instructions
it's a topology it's a way to get mail
from one place to another and that's it
so this is a description of the last two
digits is a route from an individual
post office to what's called a sectional
center facility and I will keep saying
that word but when I say it you can just
think router this is this is like a
router and a computer network it's
decides where to send things and there's
a bunch of these every time you jump
between the first three digits of an of
of the zip code you're in another one of
these trees its routing instructions
mail goes up one part of the tree hits
the apex point gets routed to another
tree and comes back down the other side
it's really simple a zip code is just
two things
it's the sexual center facility that
you're going to send the mail to and
then the destination after that so
hypothetically when you send a piece of
mail it starts off at one post office
that post office doesn't care where it's
going it's going to send it to its
sectional center facility that's aside
too it doesn't care the SCF decides the
routing every SCF knows how to get mail
to every other SCF and they have all
sorts of largest logistics systems to do
that airplanes trains boats there's
actually a post office that is still
linked by donkey train it doesn't matter
all that is hidden inside of the zip
code every post office knows go sends
that sends their mail outgoing mail to
this SCF SCF's
actually make the decisions it pushes
knowledge upwards we are gone from the
old post office system designed by Ben
Franklin where every node had to be
smart and we've gone to a centralized
system I really love the idea of this
it's a topology it's not a
rafi in any case this works this
eliminates a massive amount of waste in
the system it speeds things up post
office wants everybody to use zip code
and so they go on a propaganda spree
they invent this guy it's called mr. zip
and he is everywhere he is inside of all
sorts of posters there are toys this
bottom one it's from my personal
collection because I am a complete nerd
there is a Miss code competition because
it's the 1960s and that's the state of
gender relations at that time I didn't
make it up there's even an entire music
video they put together a band and it is
retro tastic and you should look it up
it is on youtube but make sure you leave
your speakers on low ask me how I
learned that one so zip code begins 1963
by 1967 almost every person in the
United States is using it but that
doesn't really matter because most mail
doesn't actually come from people it
comes from businesses and businesses
have zero incentive to actually switch
to this thing so the post office
introduces one and it is the reason why
we're here today the post office says to
the bulk mailers the people who were
actually send the vast majority of mail
in the country they say we're going to
give you a cheaper rate on this we're
going to let you send mail for fractions
of what a stamp actually costs but
you've got to send to everybody in the
zip code and that is why we're here
today because it completely changes
business thinking instead of thinking
about individual people or towns or your
existing customer base you have to
switch our thinking instead to zip codes
instead of thinking about individual
people you're now thinking about these
limited number of characteristics that
the post office lets you / suddenly zip
code stops being a topology a way for
sending mail from one place to another
and becomes a
fake asses geography except it breaks
all the rules I promised there would
only be one slide of actual work here
and this is the one
toddlers first law of geography this is
the basis of geography as a quantitative
science and it's incredibly simple
everything is related to everything else
but nearer things are more related than
distant things well this means two
things first off if you're a
statistician say goodbye to the concept
of Independence of variables geography
says every variable is the related to
every other variable by simple virtue of
being on earth independence has gone
away sorry bye bye classical
independence but you could pretend it's
not there you know because it kind of
makes the math easier there's a specific
there's a specific formulation of this
that's called spatial autocorrelation
and it relates to how you make a polygon
so you notice what I've not done this
entire presentation is I've not shown
you a map of zip codes because my
fundamental thesis is that zip codes are
not really polygons they're routing
information time to break that here's a
bunch of zip codes in Washington DC and
this is literally a screenshot of one of
distillery's tools for looking at things
by zip code because we work with these
bulk mail companies and they are utterly
utterly obsessed with zip codes and
other bulk mailing things is how they
make their money when you're doing an
analysis and you're looking at zip code
you have to ask yourself what is it that
I'm actually looking at a polygon is a
type of classification now if you're
doing classification problem you're
gonna do it on something that you're
actually interested in you're gonna
classify on some feature that's related
to your work when you use zip code
you've completely screwed that over
because the thing that actually
characterizes the central theme of a zip
code is what post office that it goes to
unless you're really really caring about
that post
system like the bulk mail companies who
came up with this idea did you've
introduced some weird variable into your
system it's an unconscious bias that is
about the size of bags of mail and how
big trucks are this is nothing to do
with the actual thing you're talking
about which is probably some human
geography problem you've removed the
humans from it and made it about
logistics that's not a bad thing you
know you can do a lot of things with
that
lots of things have been done with zip
codes but you got to be aware of it and
having now done this data science game
for a few years nobody really is you
just take zip codes and say it's a zip
code a zip code is a zip code is a zip
code it's not you've got to know what it
is you've got to think about what you're
actually doing to your data this is
exactly the same as if you're
classifying on something completely
unrelated you know the people who live
inside these zip codes they have nothing
to do with one another really you need
to you need to really think about that
luckily there are other options that you
can use oh and here's one of them if you
absolutely have to say inside the postal
system the post office provides an even
smaller geography I take that back let's
not say geography a bunch of points it's
called zip plus four in theory is it
plus four is somewhere between twelve
and eighteen households although I
recently came across one that was 2,000
and I have no idea how that came to be
but it's they're in there they're their
weird quirks anyway hypothetical this is
a random block in Cape May New Jersey
because I like Cape May New Jersey and
here is a zip for in this area
notice how I'm representing it as an
actual shape it's a bunch of points
these are individual households they're
still not a shape or a geography that
you can you know pump into a GIS and
generate data back on their lists of
locations at best you can make it a line
but even that is not perfectly simple
because there's other
lines in there others zip plus fours
that are overlaying it this is not an
atomic system you can be in multiple zip
codes you can be in multiple zip plus
fours at the same time this is not a 1:1
mapping there's a couple of other
gotchas you need to know about the zip
code system some of them don't actually
exist there's no physical location when
you mail your tax taxes off to the IRS
every year it has an address your mail
is not going to that address that that
routing information simply tells the
post-office to take that data and send
it to any number of different facilities
across the country it's not a real
location zip fours are really messy
Distillery currently occupies three
different floors of a building at 470
Park Avenue across those three floors
there are four different zip fours when
I was making this slide I had many
options that I could actually pick from
and all of them will do deliver to the
same location zip plus zip for zip codes
are not atomic a great New York City
example is actually Ridgewood Queens go
Ridgewood I'm from there
Ridgewood can be reached from a Brooklyn
zip code into Queens zip code because
historically it was in Brooklyn and the
system is got a really stupidly long
memory something that happened a hundred
years ago is still recorded in it today
and your mail will get delivered both
ways if the end those locations can show
up in either way in your system not a
1:1 match finally just because you're
inside of a zip code doesn't mean you're
inside the United States they're in fact
five other countries with historic
relationships to the United States that
use the zip code system so good luck
figuring those out they don't make any
sense without with the number system
seen anywhere else every US Embassy has
a zip code and they're definitely not in
the United States finally there's an
entire parallel mail routing system
that's maintained by the United States
military which has all sorts of quirks
like Africa
part of Germany in places with it move
because the troops themselves move it's
a really complicated system people tend
to take it as a zip code is here and
it's never going to move that's not
exactly true there are alternatives
things that don't really move things
that actually are meant to be used as
geographies census provides the best of
them of course their census block and
track which I'm sure we're all related I
know about there's also something called
the zip code tabulation area post office
has certain characteristics that they
sell on to the bulk mail companies in
census is actually responsible for
making them and zcta s are the how they
generate them census are a bunch of
super geography and super demography
nerds I love them they know about all
the things that I'm talking about today
and they've designed Z CTAs to be a work
around them they eliminate a lot of the
issues that we have with using zip code
as a geography the problem is they're
not exactly perfectly matched your zip
your actual zip code in the zcta that
you're in can be different and there's
no real way around that except just
knowing where the quirks are finally
there are a mess of different companies
that sell all sorts of different custom
geographies and custom data sets for zip
code and for Z in for zip plus 4 but you
need to vet your data I've seen and I've
bought a lot of this data over the years
and the quality varies wildly you will
find incredibly professional companies
that spend a lot of time actually making
sure the data is right and then you'll
find Bob's discount zip plus for a
company which is the actual name of a
company that I was once required to buy
data from I'm not kidding about that
the data was just as good as it sounded
like believe me
zip codes continuing my rant about
different geographies that in how people
abuse them we're gonna change something
a little bit different because I still
have eight minutes left and this is a
forty minute talk we're gonna talk about
trap streets and trap places this is
very different zip codes you have all
the data in seer analysis that can make
issues with it this is something else
this is something else altogether this
is where you cannot trust your actual
data you see once upon a time companies
making maps would copy from each other
and by once upon a time I mean right now
and forever so to catch one another
companies insert fake data into maps and
this here is the most famous of them all
right there in the middle is agloe New
York which does not exist and has never
existed it is in fact the initials of
Otto G Lindbergh and his assistant
Ernest Alpers
they combined the initials of their
names and they made a fake town and they
stuck it on a map while they were
working for a company called general
drafting in the 1930s if it showed up on
any other company's map aha
we got them we can go to court and we
can sue them intellectual property theft
existed back then too and this is the
only way you could catch it fast forward
to 1950s general drafting is looking at
a map of their competitor searching for
these things it's the company called
Rand McNally they're one of the largest
map makers in the world and there is a
glow new york right there
clear as day they bring them to court
you guys have stolen data off our maps
and Rand McNally is very taken aback no
we did it we sent surveyors out and we
actually went out and they recorded it
and here's the photos of agloe New York
and they're actually photos of agloe New
York and everyone is like what what the
hell are you talking about we made this
place up it's fake it's documented in
our data the problem is that they put it
on a map and the people living there
that map and discovered they're living
in agloe New York so this is the aglow
general store the photo I tried to find
a photo of this that was good quality of
the day but used to say right across the
top blue and white aglow general general
Oh general store in agloe New York
the thing is they sold SO gas which is
today Exxon Mobil in Exxon Mobil printed
maps for drivers and they license that
map data from the general drafting
company they open up the map oh hey I'm
in agloe New York let's go and that's
let's put up all sorts of different
signs about the place it's the craziest
thing it's fake data inserted into a map
that became real and here's the thing
it's not gone yet I pulled this this
morning this is the GN is a geographic
names information system this is
maintained by the USGS in the national
geospatial-intelligence agency this is
the official list of names of every
place in the United States of America
yes there is a list it does exist this
is it it's online
here's agloe New York it still exists
even though it never really existed it's
still there okay okay that's great you
know there's way more instances of these
things they're everywhere they're still
inserted into maps to this very day
OpenStreetMap recently inserted a few
and lo and behold there they are in
Apple maps and Google Maps now legal but
it's interesting to see that they are
they're copying that data at the time
without telling everyone since then
they've been forced to actually insert
the OpenStreetMaps
acknowledgement where they actually pull
that data and even then for very famous
things like Aguila which I was taught my
first year of geography it still gets
into systems hey Google still there to
this day so right on time I like when
that happens if you guys walk away with
any one thing from this talk today I
want you to do two things
first one thing think about your data
data isn't just Danish not just things
sitting in a file that are meaningless
and have no connection to anything
especially geo data geo data is
real-world data it is literally real
world data it is connected to things
that exist in the real world you have to
think about it don't just don't just
throw statistics at it don't just throw
it into a model think about what your
data really means where it came from and
how to respect it and also be a little
bit wary of it anyway my name is Peter
lens I am incredibly tired this morning
I am senior geospatial analyst on the
analytics team at distillery Inc does
anybody have any questions so it's fun a
word actually doing a migration from a
third party SMS provider who kind of has
extrapolated location data with I I'm so
sorry and I feel your pain yeah with a
lot loss so is there a cross-reference
because one of the next things after we
migrate is how accurate is this for
people who we don't have intro address
information other users what are some of
the sources whether public or private
that are best to kind of go through a
step-by-step process and vet across
other data pool so so you're not the
first person to have this problem this
is this is the basic problem in doing
doing geo-informatics luckily there is a
group called geo names they are as far
as I'm concerned the canonical location
piece of location data geonames it's
geonames org they actually call through
things like the gnis and the equivalent
in other countries and
Cole ate the best of that data into a
single database there's no single
official geospatial database for Earth
but that's as good as you're going to
get that's that's that's the first place
I would start the second thing that I
would take a look at is I would actually
look at the data itself depending on how
you said it's lat/long data correct I
would look at the actual lat/longs
themselves you can apply the same
algorithms that are used for finding
false financial data to lat/longs
this is something that I developed for
distillery and you could actually find
things that are truncated lat/longs
rounded data fake data in the system and
there's a number of different algorithms
that can do that can do this if you want
to geek out during office office hours
we can offline this but uh they work
exactly the same way financial financial
fraud modeling software works great on
location data howdy
thank you so a previous job I did I
worked a lot with geographic data and
you know the same problems were talking
about the political and geographic
visions or work different in different
countries I used to work for the UN and
you know different answers organized in
different ways in fact you could have
the exact same data just by crossing the
border looks different if you look at
Google Maps in India it looks very
different than Google Maps in Pakistan
yeah and these puter regions appear
differently in different parts of the
world so it's it's a big problem now
well I was doing anyways one common
technique people use kind of greed the
world or use different kind of
mathematical spherical techniques to
that slice up the globe and either
squares or other form of geometry and
then use that as the canonical reference
instead of some sort of population
distribution or political distribution
do you guys use anything might actually
do we built a system called geo tiles
that puts everywhere on earth inside of
a 100 meter by 100 meter square using
the NATO standard it's called the MGR s
algorithm it's blindingly fast it's it's
written in C and we we actually use that
to put all location data inside of a
cell on top of that we have a second GIS
that actually is point of interest data
actually polygons of store boundaries
and things like that so we actually
contextualize that date of both ways and
that's really valuable because most
things do not happen about places that
you know about they happen at people's
houses and parks and on the freeway and
if you're just looking at from a point
of interest point of view you're losing
much of the story the other thing about
it's great about that is that when we do
find a new place and we've loaded into
our point of interest database which is
three point five million places are
about right now in the u.s. we have
histories of that low case to some
degree inside of this grid system where
I can go back and say what happened in
these grids into the past I don't I
can't it used to be before we had that I
could only start telling stories about
places once we found out about that
place now I can have histories
I love histories histories can be
learned on
[Music]